ovation et applaudissements pour le
favori Kaven mokorfi mais ce ne sera pas
assez pour qu'il récolte les 218 voies
nécessaires pour devenir président de la
chambre
c'est le troisième poste le plus
important aux États-Unis après le
président et la vice-présidente même si
les républicains ont remporté la
majorité aux élections de mi-manda le
parti est divisé ma Corsy n'a pas à la
confiance de la frange conservatrice
républicaine tour à tour ses élus
proposent d'autres candidats
les Américains estiment que le lien de
confiance avec Washington est rompu dit
Paul gooster
je propose un dbx comme président de la
Chambre
premier vote première défaite pour Keven
moqueurphy 19 républicains s'opposent à
son élection
défait aussi au deuxième tour cette fois
c'est matgate le représentant de la
Floride des partisans de Donald Trump
qui proposent Jim Jordan le représentant
de l'Ohio comme président de la chambre
je propose Jim Jordan dit-il il est
humble et serait les meilleures
personnes pour la position
même si Jim Jordan a soutenu Kevin me
croire aussi
le rejette et au troisième tour une
autre défaite malgré le soutien cette
fois du numéro 2 républicain de la
chambre
est la bonne personne
utile mais cette fois 20 élus
républicain s'oppose aux candidats
va-t-il persister ou retirer sa
candidature au profit du numéro 2
républicain Steve scarless
les démocrates se délectent de voir
leurs adversaires se déchirer eux font
front commun depuis le début derrière
Hakim Jeffrey ce qui récolte à chaque
fois 212 voix pour les représenter
le votre prend donc demain à midi car
les élus n'ont pas réussi à s'entendre
sur l'élection d'un président de la
Chambre des Représentants pourtant après
leur victoire les républicains avaient
promis plusieurs enquêtes judiciaires
sur Joe Biden sur sa gestion de la
pandémie sa gestion du retrait des
troupes américaines d'Afghanistan encore
faudrait-il qu'ils s'entende sur
l'élection d'un président de la Chambre
ici Radio-Canada Washington